as you know yesterday Kim Kardashian
visited president Trump to talk prison
reform instantly incurring the wrath of
that perpetual scowl known as Jim Acosta
here's CNN's frown Prince lamenting our
president's lack of seriousness forget
about the fact that Kim Kardashian is
here at the White House today and what
planet that is anything resembling
normal because it's not she shouldn't be
here talking about prison reform it's
very nice that she is here but that's
not a serious thing to have happen to
here at the White House mister
sophisticated seriously does this guy
ever have any fun something tells me he
would complain about freshly laundered
pajamas it's the only good thing I could
think of I get it though Kim's not an
important celebrity the kind that showed
up when President Obama was in charge
I mean she's no John Legend am i right
Jimmy I'm gonna push the president to
get more involved in criminal justice
reform you changed your mind about
running for office give CNN the sky well
well John Legend don't hold your breath
we might just a little bit o fact is a
lot of celebrities visited Obama John
Legend jay-z Rihanna Beyonce Seinfeld
Timberlake but that never bothered Jim
so the real story is that there are
those in the media who still can't step
outside their own bias even when Trump
does something good or something they
agree with or something that other
presidents have done many times before
they act as though it's a horrible first
and it's most certainly awful
so Trump here's out of celebrity over a
case involving a woman who served 20
years of a life sentence for a
first-time nonviolent drug crime don't
you think maybe a costume would find
that a bit refreshing but it isn't about
the prisoner or Kim it's about Trump and
for the next 6 and 1/2 years it will
always be about Trump seems like Jim is
stuck in a prison of his own making nice
little package and I hand it over to you
Jesse clearly a product of bias dearly
there was one variable was Trump and in
bold story changes well done Gutfeld
take a lap Acosta you got crushed and
you know it's great then now you have
this Internet it's like an encyclopedia
of ha
yeah you go back I think he told the
late night show the other day I was just
as tough on Obama as I am on Trump and
then if you look on the internet it's
him
just giving Obama wet kisses at all
these press conferences I don't mind
Acosta I think it's fine that he does
what he does but own it you are in the
tank for the left you hate Donald Trump
don't hide behind CNN it's you know
you're biased just come to terms with it
if you were on the right and you were
harassing and lobbing loaded questions
at Obama I'm sure you'd have people
lauding you that's fine yes he would be
one I'd be like hell of a job this guy's
got a real real you know real stomach
for this but I just have to correct one
thing they're calling this woman who Kim
Kardashian is lobbying for this
first-time nonviolent drug offender
according to the AP at the time she was
arrested she was running a multi-million
dollar cocaine ring with South American
drug lords and laundering millions of
dollars still life without parole listen
maybe it was a little too harsh but
let's not characterize her as like maybe
she sold a dime bag on the street once
this is massive amounts of cocaine for
many many years yes yes yeah well there
are a lot of drug dealers who've sold
much more damaging drugs who have done
far less time and they get parole I know
it's a costume I mean I'm proud of them
because no you know I have an
affiliation in the sense that is that
was a Cuban refugee and I like to see
the American dream come true and Latin
pride and all that he's uptight and
inconsistent at times and I and I think
it is very disrespectful of President
Trump but I think Kim Kardashian going
to the White House is it's fabulous is
if that's what it takes for them to talk
about prison reform and sentencing
reform and and issues like boring topic
you need a little pizzazz you gotta have
something to get to the presidency I
mean there's so many you know
catastrophes competing for center stage
on the on the on the world platform
there you need someone like her to push
it over and I am delighted not that you
mentioned it that President Trump has
pardoned Dinesh D'Souza Dinesh D'Souza I
want him to use this port in power
a lot more I think that he hinted that
rod Blagojevich the former governor of
Illinois would be pardoned he got 18
years for saying oh man I can't wait to
get something for this seat I mean so
way it wasn't a crime at all I think
Peter Fitzgerald who's on Jim Comey's
best friend on the team you know
defending Comey he was the prosecutor
they are in Illinois it was terrible a
blog or a [ __ ] Martha Stewart I mean
she didn't she was in the clear and then
she lied to a Fed you didn't raise I
would like preemptively lobby for a
pardon from the president just in case I
want to party
Jedidiah Dana so they have time to speak
yeah I was just gonna say that it's
funny because of the issue at hand of
prison reform and you know that Acosta
agrees with this like it's very likely
so he had to even though he agrees on
the issue he had to twist and contort
himself because it's Trump that he has
to oppose it he has to have a problem
with it and I think that's when it's
interesting because when it's an issue
that you know they oppose it's one thing
but when it's an issue that you know
somebody like that probably supports and
many people do and you have to nail it
just because it's Trump that's what
makes it so funny for the audience I
think Dana well I'll talk about the
celebrity angle which is that I don't
really care what their political views
are and I don't want to read them on
Twitter necessary I don't take much talk
in them they're free to do it but it
just doesn't persuade me at all but I
would say that somebody like Angelina
Jolie when she decided to become a UN
Ambassador to talk about the plight of
children and refugees around the world
and that was effective yeah so if you
have a platform and you want to do good
with it I think that that's to be
admired I would also say though on a
part in front that was not the pardon I
was expecting today we talked a couple
of days about Matthew Charles who is
back in he's actually back in jail it's
a government error I hear that it is
being kicked around at the White House
that his sentence would be commuted or
that he would get a pardon and possibly
even this week and I think that's much
more warranted and urgent than we're
rewarding political allies and
celebrities like but he did you Jack
Johnson which is pretty great again yeah
that is great it's also posthumous this
is a guy who was actually being sent
back to prison
unnecessarily all right